moi ce qui m'a plu c'est qu'en fait il
nous a pas demandé de l'aider
franchement il nous a rien demandé
fabrice tu nous a juste demandé de faire
un beau cadeau au service à tous les
enfants qui sont dans service pédiatrie
cessa de la timone qui font ans les
infirmières sont exceptionnelles avec
tous ces petits qui sont malades
c'est beaucoup d'émotion et tous les
tous les enfants qu'on voit tous les
jours là bas avec toute l'équipe de
touche pas à mon poste
on voulait vous offrir voilà je vous le
dit plein de cadeaux et plein de jouets
pour tous les enfants de cet hôpital
[Applaudissements]
moi je vous dis merci merci
un amour ne souhaite pas la mort mais si
bien alors en question
alors
franchement c'est vraiment ça fabrice
flipo bien merci